bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport numéro 27 et c'est parti pour 26
minutes de reportages des interviews et
d'image de match les cougars ont joué ce
week-end leur demi-finale aller de
division 2 à pessac ils se sont inclinés
de justesse sur les deux manches les
joueurs d'arnaud fo sont dos au mur et
devront réagir ce samedi pour espérer
continuer leur route de leur côté
virginie et patrick ont participé il y a
dix jours à l'ultra-trail du mont-blanc
la course de l'extrême qui s'étend sur
170 km malgré l'abandon ils sont venus
nous raconter leur expérience et nous
vous ferons découvrir en fin d'émission
le nouveau lieu dédié au bloc sur saint
quentin en yvelines verticale art et
évidemment comme d'habitude en fin
d'émission tous les résultats du
week-end mais tout d'abord passons à
l'ultra trail cette course de l'extrême
le à laquelle ont participé de saint
quentinois virginie deneux ville et
patrick dubois qui sont tout près de moi
qui m'ont rejoint sur ce plateau bonsoir
à tous les deux merci d'être venu après
cette expérience assez unique il ya dix
jours vous avez donc participé à l'ultra
trail du mont blanc 170 km je le disais
première question qu'est ce qui vous a
pris de participer à 170 km 2 pour
virginie et la passion
nous avons
l'habitude de de participer à des défis
cette fois ci on est arrivé dans ce
format là de défis donc voilà nous
sommes vous êtes des trailer adhérer aux
idées dix ans donc je pense
qu'effectivement voir arriver à
participer à des courses comme ça il
faut que ce soit un mode de vie plus
qu'autre chose et là on est arrivé au
saint graal les jeux olympiques du trail
le luc mb et comment se prépare une
course comme celle ci l'ultrafrais du
mont blanc patrick
déjà pour participer à cette course là
et la fin du concret a team d âme pour
l'inscription donc dès qu'on a eu cette
inscription on a engagé un programme de
course assez dur d'ailleurs puisque
physiquement il faut être ce pour bien
se préparer moralement aussi
la télé ça je crois un petit peu voilà
week-end spécifiques notamment de
reconnaissance de cette course et on a
fait des courses intermédiaires qui nous
permettait de nous jauger voilà
exactement et le jour de la course
l'ultra trail du mont blanc c'est une
course qui est réputée à travers le
monde il n'y avait plus de 2300 trailer
sur la ligne de départ on doit avoir des
environnements des paysages uniques 1 au
milieu des montagnes
c'est le tour du mont blanc le massif du
mont blanc c'est un grand voyage
c'est
un grand jardin aussi et c'est la
montagne donc on a une dizaine de cols à
franchir trois pays a traversé
la france l'italie la suisse et re la
france pour retourner chamonix donc les
paysages sont absolument fantastiques le
val ferret italien la descente en suisse
tout ça c'est fantastique
qu'est ce qui vous a marqué le plus
justement dans ces paysages vous parlez
de vous me parlez quand on préparé
l'émission de la fouly notamment c'est
un endroit qui est assez magnifique pour
moi est le plus spectaculaire c'est les
levers de soleil puisqu'on la nuit en
cours le jour mais le matin
la montagne qui se découpe en
contre-jour avec les coureurs en
silhouette là c'est très impressionnant
et malgré les forts parce que vous
parcourez sûr sur cette épreuve
m de dénivelé positif on arrive à
admirer le paysage
oui parce que en fait la montagne vous
regarde toujours et vous êtes appelés à
vaincre donc à monter donc vous faites
des efforts musculaires vous faites
des choses hors norme qui vous permette
d'avancer
et je pense que si on a si on oublie les
douleurs
physiques physique
quand je pense que on peut réussir mais
c'est pas si vilain que dans le marathon
parle souvent du mur du 30e kilomètre là
il y en a cent soixante dix on est
presque à six fois plus comment on fait
il ya un moment c'est le mental qui
passe outre bon il ya dix les murs y en
a plusieurs en fait il ya des hauts et
du parc on appelle plus à les murs mais
en fait c'est la même chose il ya des
hauts et des bas donc l'idée c'est de
savoir gérer les eaux pas s'enflammer
parce que on a tendance à accélérer à ce
moment là c'est pas la bonne idée est de
savoir passer les bas sans que ce soit
une cause abandon justement mais il ya
on n'est pas linéaire sur une course
comme ça il faut vraiment savoir gérer
ses différentes et vous est tout le
temps en train de courir il faut bien
préciser s'il ya des moments où il ya
des moments où vous marchez vraiment où
c'est trop compliqué en fait on on garde
un rythme permanent
disons parce qu'on est soumis à des
barrières horaires donc il ya des pans
de passage à rester matic mans il ya des
temps de passage à respecter
et ces moments là sont extraordinaires
parce que on est toujours libre pour mon
cas j'étais limite et j'ai passé des
moments extraordinaires parce que j'ai
réussi à franchir quelques barrières pas
marché
mais ça a été pour moi un rêve que je
réalise et c'était formidable pour les
pour les premiers sur l'ultra trail du
mont blanc la course dure 20 heures oui
comment vous faites vous dormez il ya un
moment où on s'arrête pour se reposer ou
quand ça se passe ja je crois
12 15 ravitaillement qui permettent des
petites pauses ou des rangs pause pour
certains les grandes causes sont
possibles à condition d'être
suffisamment dans les barrières horaires
moi je suis incapable de m'arrêter je
suis
si jamais je cherche à dormir j'ai les
yeux grands ouverts et je regarde le
plafond c'est je sais pas faire mais en
revanche il est la gestion de
dépose c'est quand même important parce
que ça a été bon c'est originaire et ça
permet d'avancer plus loin hélas ces
critiques sur cette course il faut
vraiment savoir gérer ça peut-être pas
mon cas encore on va en parler là
justement vous n'avez pas fini
l'ultra-trail vous êtes arrêté au centre
18e kilomètre c'est déjà exceptionnel en
soi cette performance racontez nous ce
sont dix huitième kilomètre qu'est ce
qui s'est passé je crois que patrick
vous rejoignez virginie quelques km
auparavant voilà je rejoins virginie
qui avait pris beaucoup d'avancé
d'ailleurs qu'il y avait deux heures
d'avancé sur moi tout ce qui est énorme
et
bon malheureusement ces problèmes du
sport on a des petits problèmes
physiques physique et donc à une comme
une contracture contracture musculaire
qui l'a ralenti et du coup il s'est
passé un moment c'est que je les
rattrape et
g
comment je reste légale et
en fait quand je dis on va aller au
comment service médical à la fouly et on
a je n'ai pas encourager à continuer
donc mais je pense qu'elle aurait
continué alors et finition du tmb si
elle ne m'avez pas écouté je suis
responsable de sa défaite c'est un jeune
arabe connaît non s'il ya un goût
d'inachevé du couleurs il ya une grosse
frustration mais aussi une belle
expérience là l'échec nous par l'échec
l'abandon est une gestion bon pour moi
les c'est vrai qu' on aurait pu aller
plus loin dire que j'aurai fini ça
c'était pas évident et t'es pas 100%
responsable je me suis quand même laissé
glisser dans l'eau le tir est le confort
de la rade la douleur j'avais
effectivement une quand même une grosse
contracture qui m'avait bonne je
pourrais je boitais j'avançais plus du
tout à mon rythme normal et j'avais un
manque de plaisir sur les shows les
descentes si c'est quand même à moteur
donc mon arrêté prématurément
on aurait dû aller jusqu'au bout des
barrières on était toujours dans les
barrières et ça c'est dommage donc
maintenant on le sait et on sait
maintenant qu'on doit fonctionner tous
les deux on dit souvent que l'aco que
c'est la course d'un ultra trail du mont
blanc tout trailer doit avoir fini une
fois dans sa vie du coup ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que vous allez
repartir pour l'année prochaine mais
alors
je vous pose peut dire un petit mot
il va se compléter votre question en
fait déjà je voulais remercier déjà
toutes les personnes ils nous ont suivis
tout le long de la course par le biais
du téléphone et d'internet et je voulais
aussi félicité virginie pour tous ces
efforts qu'elle a donné pour son moral
pour sa ténacité
à vaincre tous les handicaps de la
course et je voulais louise souhaité en
fait de réaliser cette course en 2004
morose mais je crois qu'ils n'aient
succès elle le mérite parce que je suis
sûr qu'il va réussir je crois que vous
avez inscrit les apprécier d'être tiré
au sort en fait oui l'inscription 6 en
décembre on va à se réinscrire cela dit
moi j'ajoute quand même que c'est quand
même un mode de vie pour y arriver à
savoir c'est toute l'année qu'on doit
s'entraîner et que en fait il y sort à 2
il peut dire ce qu'il veut c'est une
accord à dos dites moi si je me trompe
qu'on a l'impression qu'il ya beaucoup
d'émotion qu'on vous en parlait encore
de cette cour wind ont même mis en cause
de tous les superlatifs c'est aussi un
des surnoms de l'ultra-trail du coup
qu'est ce quelle leçon vous tirez pour
dernière question de cet abandon va pas
parler d'échec mais d'abandon
je pense que dans un abandon comme ça on
apprend beaucoup de choses
il ya des choses qu'on en fera plus donc
c'est à dire on va gérer notre course
indépendamment parce que c'est pas de
course qu'on fait à deux on l'a fait
vraiment vous êtes trop préoccupés l'un
de l'autre et je t'aime voilà c'est vrai
je pense que cet abandon nous apporter
peut-être l'expérience de l'abandon
qu'on devait avoir pour un jour
peut-être y arriver moi je suis persuadé
qu'il ya des gens qui vont le faire trop
quatre fois avant d'y arriver là on a
essayé une première fois on a vu ce qui
marchait pas la deuxième ce sera la
bonne ouais si on a de la chance que
tous les ingrédients et soit rassemblée
oui on devrait y arriver super merci
beaucoup en tout cas tous les deux
d'être venu on suivra peut-être du coup
votre préparation pour la prochaine
édition mais les piliers du club fabrice
matrice voulais rajouter très rare il
est remercié le site kern aussi qu'il
nous a suivi tout le long de la course
franchement ils ont les collègues à nous
d'autres notre journaliste voir édition
spéciale est donc là dans le trade merci
beaucoup à tous les deux à bientôt pour
peut-être cette future préparation en
tout cas merci beaucoup c'est nous qui
vous remercie dans quelques semaines
vous pourrez grimper encore une fois
mais cette fois à montigny le bretonneux
verticale art une salle de bloc de 1200
m² va proposer des voies d'escaladé pour
tous les niveaux nous avons suivi les
derniers préparatifs avec claire cambier
à première vue verticale art ressemble
plus à un gigantesque puzzle qu'à une
salle de blogs et pourtant chaque
couleur de prise a une signification du
blanc le plus facile en passant par le
vert le niveau atteint hier jusqu'au
noir pour les meilleurs grimpeurs à
l'heure actuelle trois ouvreurs très les
voix de chaque jour on aura plus que des
petites crises de pied pas trop petit
pour les blocs facile et puis au début
mais les prises pas trop éloigné ensuite
on peut les mettre un peu de travers
parce que comme ça on joue avec la
notion d' équilibre etc et plus en
équilibre ou les mouvements plus
physique plus loin puis dynamique on
défend va devoir sauter faire des jetés
le projet est né il y a deux ans les
quatre dirigeants de vertical arts se
rencontrent sur les parois et décide de
s'installer dans les yvelines à montigny
le bretonneux 1200 mètres carrés sont
consacrés principalement l'escaladent
avec des voies accessibles à tous les
niveaux c'est une partie des stades est
accessible à tout le monde c'est à dire
que j'ai pas besoin d'avoir connaissance
pas sur les manips je peux arriver avec
une paire de chaussons même une paire de
baskets pour débuter et avoir accès à
l'escale
le blog se pratique sans baudrier et
paroisse allant jusqu'à 3 mètres 50
voire quatre mètres de hauteur les
grimpeurs quand ils chutent tombe sur
des tapis les sorties sont également
prévues sur des sites naturels grimpé à
vertikal-1 vous coûtera 400 euros par an
l'ouverture est prévue pour la deuxième
quinzaine de septembre
un genre au meilleur jour j'en parlais
en début d'émission les gigues mari se
sont inclinés de justesse ce week-end en
demi-finales aller de division 2 à
pessac et pour débriefer cette rencontre
le directeur sportif christophe erard
des directeurs sportifs des cougars
marvingt bonsoir à vous bonsoir je le
disais un petit petite défaite c'était
vraiment très très juste à vous perdez
deux manches de rien qu'est ce qu'il a
manqué sur ce premier set première
demi-finale cette demi finale aller
apparemment c'était très serré bon moi
j'étais pas je faisais pas partie de
l'ue placement donc j'ai entendu un
petit peu parlé des matches
apparemment n'a pas déjà on n'a pas très
bien joué il nous manquait il manquait
quelques joueurs importants pendant
quatre cinq joueurs importants qu'il est
et puis on n'a pas frappé on a permis à
sept points pas beaucoup frappé on a mis
cinq points je compte en chaque match
mais ça n'a pas suffi pour oui oui tout
à fait et alors qu'est-ce qui effaceront
c'est une demi-finale très compliqué
puisque vous vous allez vite vous avez
terminé la saison régulière deuxième
pessac 3e 3e en c1 sainte séraphine un
petit peu difficile sur la saison
régulière vous aviez gagné trois manches
sur quatre puisque sur les maths les
matches aller retour vous allez nous
étions imposés même parfois largement
ouais ça reste des deux derniers matches
avant de gagner de 10 points je pense
que peut-être les que l'équipe de pessac
s'étaient pas déplacés peut-être 100%
avec
l'ensemble des joueurs de l'équipe
première là on a eu affaire certainement
à la vraie équipe de pessac nous il
manquait quelques joueurs
c'est pas passé mais de caisse qui est
qu'est-ce qui va être motivant et
surtout le discours qu'elle va quel va
être le discours cette semaine à
l'entraînement pour les joueurs là c'est
rien n'est perdu le discours maintenant
il est facile c'est que si on gagne on
gagne pas tous les matches qui restent
on va là on arrête là donc il faut
gagner trois matches ce n'est pas
impossible mais il faut gagner les trois
les matches un par un les trois qui
viennent il reste trois matches je le
rappelle ainsi au meilleur des 5 5 la
première équipe qui gagne trois matches
qui passent en finale on a perdu les
deux premiers donc j'ai nommé en fait le
droit à l'erreur on sait que c'est
possible ça c'est déjà arrivé on peut le
faire et la première manche
justement ce samedi qui va qui va se
dérouler du coup à montigny cette magie
à 14 heures ça va être la survie est
basse et ça c'est peut-être le dernier
match de la saison donc il faut il faut
y aller j'espère tout le monde sera là
que tous les joueurs sont en forme
qu'on aura un beau match quoi en cas de
défaite
cette demi-finale perdue est ce que
c'est un échec au niveau de la saison
parce que l'objectif l'objectif c'est
d'aller en finale c'est de gagner donc
forcément je pense que on sera déçu si
on va pas en finale après c'est le voilà
c'est le sport on peut pas aller en
finale chaque année et gagner mais bon
l'objectif c'est effectivement d'aller
en finale par rapport au niveau de
l'équipe c'est oui on espérait être en
fils on espère toujours être en finale
et si possible à gagner c'est faisable
donc forcément si on ne fait pas on sera
un peu déçu qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui
va pouvoir justement faire la différence
sur un match comme ça décisif ça va être
plus le mental que on va dire les
schémas ce standard de jeu il ya
plusieurs choses il ya nos lanceurs
falloir que nos lanceurs lance bien il
faut que les adversaires marquent pas
beaucoup de points et puis nous on va
falloir qu'on frappe un peu plus que
voilà on sait que on finit toujours bien
la saison en juillet il ya toujours
cette trêve de l'été qui ça casse un
trailer qui casse un petit peu le rythme
et qui fait qu'on a un petit peu de mal
à repartir
et donc falloir y aller et frappé mettre
la balle en jeu il frappe et marquer des
points oui puisqu'en fait il faut le
rappeler la saison de baseball en france
il ya une grosse coupure entre bafin
jours
maintenant les 10 isolant les divisions
général vision de ces essais ramène vers
le 15 juillet et puis sartre ans on a
repris le 20 heures peu d'entraînement
de 20,8 à peu près donc il ya un mois un
gros mois de coupure c'est presque the
season finale en fait surtout que
l'était c'est normalement la meilleure
saison pour jouer donc un général dans
beaucoup de pays ça s'arrête pas mais
bon en france y est les vacances peut
pas en première division et joue un peu
plus un peu plus longtemps mais la
coupure des vacances elle est allée
sacré on a du mal à les contrer ça
rappelez-nous un pur pour mémoire pour
les téléspectateurs le règlement de la
montée de division de la division une là
pour l'instant vous êtes vous avez fini
pour aller parmi les quatre premiers
comment ça se passe pour la suite le
premier le premier pour monter dans en
première division venez un final ça sera
ça sera quand même un échec si vous
montez pas
pour l'instant même le but c'est pas
forcément de monter le but c'est de
gagner le championnat parce que ça on
peut le faire après si on gagne le
championnat ça va être une autre
question ça va être il va falloir voir
si on a l'effectif pour monter concédé
qu'il ya vraiment un palier c'est
difficile on a déjà vécu donc on sait
que monter en première ligne a vraiment
les grosses équipes et si nous on va
falloir voir effective si on perd pas de
joueurs ça voudrait dire qu'il va
falloir se renforcer forcément avec
l'équipe actuelle avec les moyens qu'on
met actuellement ça serait difficile de
de se tenir de jouer une bonne place en
première division ça veut dire forcément
dû des renforts voilà donc après c'est
autre chose on va déjà essayer de gagner
déjà ça commence par samedi c'est la
scène rendez vous ce samedi 14 heures
pour le premier match des mets le match
commence à 14h ça dure à peu près de 2h
2h30 pour voir peut-être les cougars
survivre encore doivent être démolies si
on en arrivait à gagner le premier match
sauf à l'image de samedi parce qu'on va
y aura un match dimanche matin 11 heures
et en espérant le troisième dans la
foulée vers 15 heures très bien on
suivra ça de près merci christophe
d'être passés sur le 7-8 sport et donc à
samedi pour cette demi-finale qui risque
d'être haletante du côté de montigny
merci beaucoup dans six endroits ce
week-end les clubs allaient à la pêche
aux inscriptions et aux adhérents au
forum des associations nous nous sommes
arrêtés dans les allées de coignières
avec la compagnie des archers et vous
allez voir qu'un club de tir à l'arc
peut être très surprenant images de
quercamps bien a priori la compagnie des
archers de coignières semble être un
club comme les autres lors du forum des
associations le président michel salles
bien présenter ses activités mais son
club est aussi une compagnie et cela
fait toute la différence on respecte
l'archerie on a les décode dons à
destination de chevalier chez nous on
suit la tradition qui remonte du
moyen-âge tous les ans la compagnie
participe au bouquet traditionnels le
défilé national des archers de france et
de navarre mais le temps fort inspiré
des temps anciens restent l'adoubement
sur proposition de la compagnie
uniquement il se compose de deux temps
un rite d'initiation une cérémonie
officielle à l'église il ya des
cérémonies secrètes alors il faut
d'abord être accepté par les autres
chevaliers archers et puis à des
cérémonies secrètes espace d'initiation
un petit peu comme un rite initiatique
or entraîneur à une secte mais charest
n'est pas une secte mais c'est un petit
peu ça donc c'est secret on n'a pas le
droit de révéler ce qui ce temps ça se
passe cet honneur n'a été attribuée qu'à
une centaine de chevalier dans le
département mais la compagnie chinoise
est avant tout un club qui apprend à
tirer aux jeunes dès l'âge de 9 ans
adoubé ou pas leurs obsessions reste la
même visée ce fameux centre jours allez
c'est parti pour les résultats du
week-end
tout d'abord place au football troisième
journée de division d'honneur ce
week-end versailles se déplaçait à
l'entendre c'est un droit sagra siens et
les joueurs de david giguet vous allez
le voir à l'écran se sont inclinés 1 but
à 0 les versaillais font du surplace
dans ce début de saison ils sont
désormais onzièmes au classement que
vous allez voir apparaître avec
seulement 5 petits points et a déjà sept
longueurs du leader créteil lusitanos en
promotion d'honneur le championnat
reprenait ses droits ce week-end dans la
poule b et rap s'est imposé plutôt
tranquillement sur la pelouse du mantois
2 à 0 les trappistes lance idéalement
leur saison et sont déjà dans le bon
wagon dont la poule c et guyancourt
recevait montfermeil au stade maurice
baquet coupable d'une entame de match
assez timide à l'aiguillon courtois en
rouge encaisse très vite leur premier
but de la saison mais au retour des
vestiaires ils réagissent et prennent le
jeu à leur compte la solution va arriver
sur coup de pied arrêté voilà celui là
avec une tête magnifique décroisée dans
le petit filet on le revoit au ralenti
coups de pied arrêtés des 30 mètres les
joueurs du jus de dahlman rose aurait
même pu s'imposer 1-6 date à conduire
courtois n'avait pas perdu ce face à
face à noter les dernières minutes de la
rencontre très houleuse quelques
bousculades et décisions arbitrales non
respecté par les joueurs de mon fermé
qui ont vu l'expulsion d'un joueur de
seine-saint-denis score final 1 partout
un résultat qui satisfait jus de talent
morose le nouvel entraîneur guyancourt
toi
ces premiers matchs donc les équipes
essaient de trouver un peu de réglages
donc chacun a eu sa mi temps donc je
pense que son ensemble même si en fin de
match on aurait pu je pense mettre ce
deuxième but pour le mettre à l'abri
donc l'égalisation se pensant sur
l'ensemble et émérite et donc va y avoir
du réglage des réglages à faire ses
débuts de saison donc ce qui était
important c'était c'était au moins de
prendre deux points et puis de ne pas
perdre ce match parce qu'on aurait pu en
première mi-temps en prendre un ou deux
qui on en était en difficulté on est en
2ème mi temps 10 versa on aurait pu
aussi gagner ce match donc à
l'entraînement travailler et puis les
réglages ça va venir en football féminin
en division de montigny ouvrait sa
saison à gravelines les joueuses de
jordanie grossesse sont sèchement
incliné 1-4 buses à gravelines confirme
sa réputation de bête noire des animaux
ten en neuf confrontations directes
elles n'ont jamais perdu face aux
saint-quentinoise vous le savez dans les
yvelines les huit communes ont fait le
choix de la réforme des rythmes
scolaires mais cela impacte également
les clubs au district des yvelines on
attend les vacances de la toussaint pour
aménager les emplois du temps la
demi-journée supplémentaire va
bouleverser complètement l'organisation
des entraînements
joue le samedi les u 6 jusqu'aux u13
donc on a une grande partie de 20 à 45 %
de notre effectif qui jouent le samedi
matin d'une part oussame ben ali et donc
par conséquent il faut qu'on en tienne
compte et ça on voit si remettre mais là
avec neuf comédiens ya aucune commune
qui ai décidé de de recourir au travail
à l'école le samedi matin en rugby ce
week-end le stade du bout des clos à
maurepas accueil est une rencontre
internationale de rugby d'ailleurs entre
les jeunes les moins de 19 ans du stade
français la belgique sur le banc de
touche parisien rémy mathias et ludovic
guillaumot remplacé sébastien ami a pour
l'instant ils apprennent à connaître
leur nouvel effectif sur ce dernier
match de préparation avant l'ouverture
du championnat l'intensité physique
étaient présentes ce qui permet aux
stadistes de s'imposer 31 à 27 les
entraîneurs parisiens attendent tout de
même la fin des matches aller un pour se
fixer un objectif de fin de saison et il
espère pouvoir bénéficier des
infrastructures du nouveau stade jean
bouin pour l'instant la préparation se
passe bien même si tout n'est pas encore
parfait justement le match amical va
nous permettre de voir où on en est pour
débuter le championnat la semaine
prochaine après justement les premiers
matches nous nous
nous permet de déterminer les objectifs
de fin de saison c'est à dire que là
il ya beaucoup de points
d'interrogations sur tout ça donc c'est
pourtant aujourd'hui déjà voilà on va
essayer de valider est ce qu'on a
travaillé sur la touche sur la
circulation offensives et sur le système
de relance et après on verra au fur et à
mesure on aimerait bien postuler pour
pour avoir les infrastructures de gens -
qui sont pour les propos l'instant donc
avoir un directeur sportif donc voix et
avec les dirigeants du stade voir s'il
ya possibilité de profiter des
installations tout neuf qui permettrait
nous on est persuadé de faim roulement
sans déranger les pros depuis pouvoir
utiliser l'installation et et donc
d'optimiser notre temps de travail pour
les prépa physique et pour nous mêmes
la saison de national de basket reprend
ses droits dans deux semaines les
féminines de l'entente le
chesnay-versailles enchaîne les matches
amicaux ce jeudi les joueuses de
stéphane drolet recevait le club tchèque
de kara 39 4e de la ligue nationale
malgré une belle résistance les
versaillais se sont inclinés de 12
points 77 à 65 ans course d'orientation
ensuite aux championnats de france 3
orienteurs de lui en cours ont décroché
leur sélection pour les championnats
d'europe juniors à saint-etienne du 4 au
6 octobre prochain de gauche à droite
vous avez vu les photos il s'agissait
des frères roturier quentin et maxime et
de lauriane beau visage chez les
féminines à noter que quand un roturier
que vous voyez à l'écran a également
obtenu sa sélection pour la catégorie
moins de 18 ans après une participation
aux championnats du monde fin juin et
une 4e place aux championnats de france
il ya quelques jours 2013 est plutôt une
saison réussie pour le jeune saint
quentinois ont parlé tout à l'heure du
forum des associations de coignières et
bien d'autres clubs étaient présents a
mis à part le la compagnie des archers
c'était le cas du club de plongée qui
propose du tir subaquatique en france
c'est une toute petite fédération il ya
seulement 2 coûte 200 compétiteurs en
quoi cela consiste réponse au micro de
claire cambier
le tir sur cible subaquatique se
pratique avec une arbalète
comme les abeilles de chasse sous marine
qui peuvent être perfectionnée donc avec
un viseur en plus et on tire sur des
cibles en polystyrène qui sont tenus
d'en importer cible et le tout on
appelait
une dernière info plutôt inscriptions
même dans un peu plus d'un mois aura
lieu maintenant la désormais
traditionnelle édition de l'ekiden c'est
ce marathon en relais qui se court à la
base de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines vous pouvez encore vous
inscrire exclusivement sur internet un
hôtel bien à la bresse qui s'affiche en
bas de votre écran et maintenant les un
jardin place à l'agenda du week-end
prochain au programme vous pourrez
revoir la reprise de plaisir au stade
robert barran c'est du rugby en fédérale
3 face à l'union des bords de marne coup
d'envoi à 15 heures et vous pourrez vous
rendre au stade jean marie salles à
montigny-le-bretonneux pour soutenir les
cougars dans leur demi-finale retour de
playoffs face à pessac première manche
samedi à 14 heures et enfin vous pourrez
découvrir le golf si vous le souhaitez
dès ce vendredi 13 septembre lors des
portes ouvertes du blue green à la base
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est la fin de ce set 8 sport merci de
l'avoir suivi une nouvelle fois
n'hésitez pas à le commenter un sur les
réseaux sociaux et sur twitter avec le
hashtag le 7-8 sport tout attaché bonne
soirée à la semaine prochaine